you're wondering
what exactly bar charts are and, above
all, how can I easily create bar charts
online
? I'll show you both in this short tutorial, so
let's start.
Bar charts or column
charts are one of the most
common charts in
scientific work and they
are mostly  used to display either
frequencies or averages of
different groups
depending on how the bars are arranged a
distinction is made between vertical and
horizontal width
charts whether horizontal or
vertical the information contained is
exactly the same the bars are only drawn
once horizontally and once vertically
i labeled both
variants as a pictogram in the
literature, the case on the left is also
often referred to as a column chart and
the case on the right as a bar chart,
each individual bar reflects a
group or
category  eg each bar could reflect a
possible dessert in a restaurant
let's say this is
ice cream cake ton hat and cheese tyler the height
of the bar can represent different
parameters in most cases frequencies or mean values ​​are given in the
case of frequencies
we would eg count how
much of  which dessert was ordered in a
restaurant in the case of
average values ​​we could, for example, display
the average
calorie content of the food let's go into both cases
more precisely let's start
with the frequencies let's say no in the
hospital since the beginning of the month
every patient has had a fall  or
patients documented the first
fall happened in the corridor the second in the
bathroom the third again in the corridor and
so on and so forth now you draw
the two axes and tricks on the
x-axis the different
categories there is no bathroom
lounge and  sickroom
next  you simply count how often a
fall has taken place
in the corridor, so you go to the table here and
just go through how often there was a fall in the corridor,
let's say there were six falls,
so let's show the first bar 6
units up and write
one here  saxon let's see how often
a fall has occurred in the bathroom
let's say 22 times how often a fall
has occurred in the lounge and
how often in the sickroom now we have
four bars, each with its height
showing how often a
collapse has taken place at the respective location now
Of course we can still
sort the bar chart by dragging the bar with the
largest value to the front and
taking the bar with the smallest value
last. Now we have a nice
bar chart by sorting the drop in
the order of the frequencies of
falls in a small house
you
can now read off the relative frequencies instead of the absolute
frequencies  f being carried then shows us that
the gram does not show us how often a fall
has taken place at the respective location, but
what percentage of all the falls it is
, the height of the two remains the
same, but the y-
axis does not show the frequency
, but the frequency  the percentage and
information in the margin bar charts
are the graphic counterpart to
frequency tables in a frequency table
the absolute and
relative frequencies of a
categorical variable are plotted in the same way as in a bar
chart bathroom occurs 22 times which corresponds to
37.9 percent hospital room and  17
times before and lounge 13 times therefore
we have the same information here
as in a bar chart whether you
use a bar chart in a scientific work or a
frequency table it is a matter of
taste
now you can also look at the consequences of the fall in addition to the
location
at every s  turz the
consequences of a fall were documented from one no injury
to four serious injuries
because we have a
ranking here the bars will
not be sorted by size in this case
but by the order of
the individual groups no injury
occurred six times minimal
injury 25 times a medium one
injury has occurred 15 times
and serious injury has occurred 12 times
and in the final step we can
now look at the location and fall sequences in a
copied bar graph
against two categorical variables in front of which
copied bar graphs
can be created in a copied
two grams the bars
summarized in groups the groups
result from the categories of one of
the two variables the categories of the
other variable are represented by
different colors
in our example the groups are formed with the help of the
variable sturz Folge
and the category of the variable
w  place are highlighted with different
colors this can of course also be
reversed in copied
bar charts either the
frequency, the percentage or the percentage
in the respective groups can
be entered before we come to the two
charts in which mean
values ​​are displayed and what in the case of the error
both  first of all i will show you
how you can create both diagrams for frequencies
online with the app for
this you simply go to
the link you will find in the video
description and copy your own
data in this table
then the names of the
variables to halter fall sequence below  fall
location time of day and gender in this
case datatec has automatically recognized the fall consequences
as a metric variable
but we want it to be an
original variable so we change
that under variable view
to create charts you can
either stay on the descriptive stats tab
or you go  on
the chart tab depending on which
variable or variables you
select, datatec creates the appropriate chart here,
let's say you
select the fall location, then the data tab creates
a bar chart for the fall location, now
you can choose whether you
want the percentages or the
valid percentages to be displayed for the frequencies
you can choose between vertical
and horizontal bar charts
you can draw the hpa retro line
and determine the size
if you click on the headings or on
the axis labels
you can change them
you can also
change the font and font size under settings  if you only
click on the second variable fall sequence you get
a copied bar chart for the
variable fall location and fall from
to create bar charts for frequencies
always need categorical so
original or nominal variables if
you get proud location and old on
clicks, for example  t you also put out a
bar chart but not with
frequencies but with the
mean values ​​you see, for example, how old the people are
on average who
like to fall or how old the people are
on average who have fallen in the
bathroom
you can also see the error here
output bars but slowly
we will now go through this in more detail
with bar charts
not only frequencies but also
other characteristic values ​​can of course be displayed in
addition to frequencies they are often shown mean values ​​for
this there must be a
categorical and a metric variant in
front of it let's say you have people in a
questionnaire  your highest
educational qualification and your net
monthly salary here you have the
list with the answers the first
person answered compulsory school and 2500
euros the second person high school and 3200
euros and so on and so forth now
you can plot this again in a
bar chart the categories
are without a degree from compulsory school Abitur
and university now does not show
the frequencies of the categories in the
diagram but
the mean values ​​of the respective group on average, the
person without a degree has a salary of
1619 euros, the people with compulsory school have
a salary of 1804 euros, those with a high school diploma
of
2116  and those with high school from
2216 euros when bar charts are
used to add the mean
value, error bars are very often also
drawn in and we’re going to
work a lot on that now are a graphical
representation of the scattering of data with
error bars you can see how accurate
your measurement is and get a
overview of what range your data
falls in error both give error
usually as standard
deviation standard error or 95 percent confidence interval
standard deviation is used
error bars give the
average distance of individual
values ​​from the mean let's say
the bar  en give the average
temperature of four cities in
april if you had to estimate is how
warm it is in a city on a
certain day next april
you would estimate the mean value let's
say in stat de the mean value is 13
degrees the standard deviation is now  how
badly you misjudge, on average,
estimating 13 degrees for any given day.
the second option is
to use the standard error. the standard error
is calculated by dividing the
standard deviation by the
sample size,
and the third option is the 95
percent confidence interval  specifying
that 95 percent confidence interval gives
you the range in which the mean
value is 95 percent want more detailed
information on the confidence interval
just watch
my video for this if you use dated
and select age and fall location then
you can choose here if and if
yes, what error bar do you have
I hope you liked the video and
we'll see you next time